MALE SPEAKER: Good morning.
Welcome to Authors
at Google Cambridge.
And welcome to Pride Week.
It's my enormous pleasure
to kick off Pride Week here
in Cambridge by introducing four
exceptionally talented writers.
They happen to be trans women.
They are part of the growing
group of Topside Press writers
who are giving voice to
people whose voices have long
since been denied in
the publishing world
and who are changing lives
even as we stand here.
Today, we have four writers who
are part of the Topside Press
Northeastern Tour.
Two writers will be
back in Cambridge a week
from tomorrow, the 17th, at a
location whose name I forget,
but who Red Durkin can
probably remind us of.
But this morning, we welcome
Imogen Binnie, Red Durkin,
Casey Plett, and
Jeanne Thornton.
Imogen Binnie writes a
monthly column in "Maximum
Rock'n'Roll" magazine as well
as the zines "The Fact That
It's Funny Doesn't Make It A
Joke" and "Stereotype Threat."
She was a contributor
to the Topside Press
"The Collection-- Short Fiction
from the Transgender Vanguard,"
which I highly recommend.
She was recently named a
recipient of the 2014 Betty
Burzon Emerging Writer Award.
Also, her novel
"Nevada," which is
available in the back of
the room after the talk,
has been the recent subject
of not one, not two,
but three video games
produced at one of our most
prestigious engineering
universities,
Georgia Tech University,
alongside another classic
of the genre, James
Baldwin's "Giovanni's Room."
So there you have it.
If you never thought you
would see a video game based
on "Giovanni's Room"-- I
never did-- we're both wrong.
Red Durkin is, for
obscure reasons,
sadly by default, the prettiest
and funniest stand-up comedian
in New York City now.
RED DURKIN: According to
the comedian reporter.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: She's also
a very talented writer
and a dogged activist.
She is the managing
editor of PrettyQueer.com.
She has written
nine zines and was
featured in the final issue
of Punk Planet magazine
and contributed to
"The Collection."
Casey Plett has just
published a collection
of stories, "A
Safe Girl to Love,"
the dedication of which is
particularly near to my heart.
Previously, she wrote a
column on transitioning
for McSweeney's
Internet Tendency
and contributed to
"The Collection."
And Jeanne Thornton
is the author
of "The Black Emerald," which
is forthcoming later this year,
and "The Dream of
Doctor Bantam,"
which was a Lambda
Award finalist for 2012,
as well as the web comics
"Bad Mother" and "The Man
Who Hates Fun."
Please join me in welcoming
these four very talented
writers.
[APPLAUSE]
JEANNE THORNTON: Hi, everybody.
I'm Jeanne Thornton.
Oh, that's creepy.
I don't want to look at that.
OK.
So I'm going to read to you
from the beginning of my book
"The Dream of Doctor Bantam,"
which is in the back.
And let's just go.
Let's just get this started.
OK.
It's the beginning of the book.
You need no context.
There's the drawing of an IHOP.
It's cool.
"When Tabitha Thatch argued,
her little sister Julie
always thought about cats.
It was rare that Tabitha
argued, much more common
that she agreed to
rules or demands
her mother or the
world imposed on her,
and then did the opposite
of what she'd agreed to.
But when she did argue,
her jaw relaxed open
and her voice,
high-pitched and ragged,
folded in on itself
in 100 tissue paper
layers of connotation,
implication, meaning,
all of her yowling 'protest' in
a way that you couldn't ignore.
You could listen to Tabitha
arguing like a cat for hours.
Julie-- her own voice
like a dog's, she thought,
short and hoarse and barky-- had
listened to Tabitha for hours.
You could listen
and you would be
struck by how raw and
vibrant that voice was.
But then you would realize
that Tabitha was just
saying she was going
to go to the mall
and buy Adderall to
swallow with beer
and then hang around the food
court talking about the Misfits
with some college kid.
In a raw and vibrant and catlike
way she would tell you that.
And you would believe in her.
Linda, Tabitha and
Julie's mother,
had never been vulnerable
to Tabitha's voice.
And Julie had always hated
Linda a little bit for that.
They were fighting
now, Tabs and Linda.
Their voices came through
the walls of Julie's bedroom
like foreign talk
radio on the AM dial.
Julie sat up on the
edge of her bed,
recently stripped of its
alphabet-patterned case
and replaced with a more
grown-up deep green color
that reminded her
of rainforests.
She felt her long hair sticking
up in crazy roller-coaster
loops at the back of her head.
The air of the room
was somehow just wrong.
Like Lucy in 'Voyage of the
Dawn Treader,' she had slipped
into another dimension, one in
which she was not able to get
any sleep before her
algebra test the next day,
one in which the red digital
clock was blinking midnight
at her in some sick parody
of 'good morning.' She went
into the hallway, still in her
white Apple Records T-shirt
and boxers, sat on the floor
outside Linda's bedroom,
curled her legs up to her
body, and listened to them.
Everything has to have a
reeeason, that's your problem,
Tabitha was saying.
What if my reason
is that I just want
to spend all day lying
in a field or something?
And writing long letters
to ex-boyfriends?
What if that's my reason?
I don't give a shit what
your reason is, Linda said.
I don't care how
boring or irrelevant
you think your
classes are, either.
You think I don't spend
eight or nine hours a day
doing boring and
irrelevant stuff?
I think you're
spending right now
doing boring and irrelevant
stuff, said Tabitha.
Does right now count toward
those eight or nine hours?
It's called
survival, said Linda.
You do what you have
to in order to survive.
It's not called
fun or quit school
so I could go out with boys and
work at a fucking video arcade
and smoke pot in
the house all day.
At least smoke
pot in the garage.
I'm an adult, said Tabitha.
I can possibly make decisions
without subjecting them
to some neurotic
process of analysis
about what might
possibly go wrong or--
You're 17, said Linda.
And the video arcade is a good
job, said Tabitha, mother.
Linda laughed.
Julie buried her cheeks deeper
into her bare bony knees.
There are no good
jobs, Linda said.
There are only lucrative
jobs that you hate.
Your job is neither
lucrative, nor do you hate it.
I'll move out, said Tabitha.
That got a laugh.
That's cool.
I like this place.
"I'll move out, said Tabitha.
I'll move out, and maybe
Julie will come with me.
And you won't have us
hanging around all the time
making your life miserable.
You're stoned, said Linda.
I'm not going to argue with
you while you're stoned.
Ewwww, you're
stoooooned, said Tabitha.
Get out of my room, said Linda.
go to bed.
And you're going back to
school in the morning.
You're going to tell them
you changed your mind
about leaving.
Ewwww, get out of my
rooooom, said Tabitha.
The TV came on immediately,
some infomercial.
There was a snort
and then a stomp.
And then Julie's eyes were
blinded by the lamplight.
Tabitha stormed into the
hallway and slammed the door
behind her.
She turned and her eyes fell to
the ball of Julie at her feet.
She stopped before her sister.
What the fuck are you doing
in the hallway? she asked.
Were you spying on us?
Yes, Julie said.
Tabitha stared down at her.
Julie stared back up.
When Tabitha got like this,
you could not be reasonable.
You only had to match
her, crazy for crazy.
Even in the dark hallway,
Julie thought her older sister
was very beautiful-- her
hair, hay-blonde like Julie's,
bleached and highlighted
in pink like celery stalks
in red water.
Her skirt torn, her
stockings striped,
her shirt full of rhinestones
like the constellations
that Julie liked to
memorize from books
and try to see through the
fluorescent haze of Austin
streetlights.
The rhinestones
spelled out NO FUTURE.
Tabitha put her hands on her
hips and pursed her mouth.
Her lips were painted in
red and outlined in black.
The epaulets of
her leather jacket
rose and fell as she breathed.
Come on, Tabitha said.
Let's get out of here.
Where are we going?
Julie asked.
Anywhere but here, said Tabitha.
I don't know.
We'll get pancakes.
Come on.
Julie got up, the
shoulders of her T-shirt
nearly even with
Tabitha's epaulets.
Somehow, at 13, she had
become as tall as her sister
when she wasn't
paying attention.
Let me go get
dressed, she asked.
You'll take forever,
said Tabitha.
Come on, trust me.
Let's just go.
It's the millennium.
Julie's flip-flops were
stacked under the coat rack
by the door.
She put them on and
followed Tabitha out
into the front yard,
crossed the lawn
in her Apple Records
T-shirt and boxers.
Her legs shivered
in the spring night
and every window in
every neighbor's house
could have been an eyeball.
She got into the car
next to her sister.
She lit a cigarette, a
tulip of fire surrounded
by the black petals
of her painted nails.
Against the light her eyes
were red at the edges.
She turned the key.
They didn't talk as they
drove down 2222 and merged
onto the highway bearing south.
One of Tabitha's
Smashing Pumpkins CDs
was blaring quietly.
Tabitha tossed her filter out
the window, licked her lips,
and then looked over at Julie.
Shit, she said.
I can't take you to get
pancakes in your boxers.
I must be losing my mind.
She giggled again, and she
veered off the highway,
throwing Julie's shoulders
against the seatbelt.
Be careful, Julie hissed.
They fishtailed
under the overpass.
The CD played on.
Tabitha flicked her blinkers
off and on in time with it
while Julie stared at her,
dug her nails into her seat.
They pulled into the parking
lot of an all-night Wal-Mart.
Tabitha opened the door
and swung her legs out.
What are we doing
here, Julie said.
What dress size are
you? said Tabitha.
I have no idea, said Julie.
Can we just go home?
No, said Tabitha happily.
Come on, guess.
You have to know
your dress size.
Four, Julie guessed.
Four, nodded Tabitha.
She took the keys out of the
ignition, tossed them to Julie,
and shut the door.
You can listen to the CD
if you want, she said.
Just, if you do, leave the
window rolled down a little.
Otherwise gases and stuff
will come in from the engine
and they'll kill you.
She gave a two-fingered
Cub Scout salute
and then jogged off
toward the store.
Julie sat alone in the car for a
minute, listening to the engine
creak and settle
and needing to pee.
And then she picked up the keys
and turned on the CD player.
There was a new song,
quiet and creepy.
A man was pushing a shopping
cart filled with bulky trash
bags near the curb by the dark
part at the edge of the store,
a gray hood bunched
up around his skull.
She looked at the
window, half-rolled down,
and wondered if you could smell
the gas from the engine killing
you and if the sleepiness
she felt in her temples
meant that it might
already be too late.
She turned off the CD, but
that only made the dread worse,
and she couldn't figure
out how to turn it back on.
You took forever,
she said to Tabitha
when her sister hustled
back into the car
and handed her a fat
white shopping bag.
Size four, said Tabitha.
Put 'em on.
There was a pair of
jeans in the bag.
Where am I supposed to
put them on? asked Julie.
Jesus, said Tabitha.
The back seat.
Where else do you
change clothes in a car?
Julie tapped her
fingers against the bag
and then clambered
between the seats.
The leather in the back
reeked of pot and incense.
And she stretched her
legs out over the piles
of forgotten school papers
that filled up Tabitha's car.
A skeleton keychain, long
abandoned, dug into her behind.
The windows are open, she said.
Right, said Tabitha.
People only notice parked
cars if the windows get all
fogged up.
So even though it may seem like
the exact wrong thing to do,
if you're getting, like,
physical with a boy,
you'll want to leave
the windows open.
Remember that.
You're stupid and
stoned, said Julie.
I'm never getting
physical with a boy.
With a girl, then,
Tabitha shrugged.
Whatever.
It's the millennium.
Julie flushed in the dark.
You're stoned, she repeated.
Then she closed her eyes.
She pretended that
she was not sitting
in a parked car with her
sister, and she shrugged off
her boxers.
She hurried the new
jeans on, arched her back
to struggle with the last two
inches of hip and the snaps.
They're too tight, she breathed.
Size four my ass, said Tabitha.
Come on, squeeze 'em in there.
She still managed it, snapped,
zipped, tried to breathe,
and succeeded.
She sat up-- still OK.
She opened the door and
began to circle the car,
walking the pants on.
The jeans were boot cut,
screenprinted neon flames
rising from the cuffs.
She winced as her
bare soles pushed
against the
cracked-glass asphalt.
She was walking commando
through a parking
lot at night in tight
jeans she had just
gone out and bought
with her sister, why
not, snap, like that.
And Tabitha was
behind the wheel,
stoned and fiddling with the CD
player, giving her a thumbs up
and nodding in time with "Cherub
Rock" out of the speakers.
And she looked at her
sister and she loved her.
You like 'em? asked Tabitha.
They're not like cutting off
circulation in your legs?
They're the best pants
ever, Julie said.
You make them
work, said Tabitha.
Come on, let's get pancakes.
And so they pulled
out of the parking lot
and onto the highway like a
jet screaming in takeoff--
a jet that sounded
like Billy Corgan
and stank like an ashtray
at a renaissance fair--
and Julie decided
that there would never
be a better moment than
this in her entire life."
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
RED DURKIN: My
name is Red Durkin.
I've got about an hour's sleep
in me, so this will be fun.
It'll be great.
Also, I was introduced--
I'm a comedian,
but my writing is really
not very funny, so.
I'm going to read my story
from "The Collection," which
is titled "A Roman Incident."
And all you need
to know about that
is that it's the term for
when somebody throws up
during an eating contest.
"To Charlie's immediate
left stood a man
who had once eaten 21 pounds
of grits in 10 minutes.
All along the table
in front of her,
clad in the same free
T-shirt she wore,
adventurous amateurs
stood shoulder-to-shoulder
with vetted professionals who
made their living rushing down
enough food to kill civilians.
Charlie prayed--" oh, jeez.
Ah, it went away.
All right.
I'll try to not let that
happen again, sorry.
"Charlie prayed that
in 10 short minutes,
she'd have earned a place in
the fellowship of the latter.
Icy terror filled
her empty stomach.
She could afford to
lose some of her nerve,
but none of her appetite.
She closed her eyes and
counted down from 10.
At zero, the world
completely exploded.
Lights flashed, buzzers blared,
and a crowd of thousands,
surging like a bore tide,
crashed into the security gate.
Their cacophonous excitement
splashed onto the stage,
along with waves of their beer.
Charlie was face down in her
fourth mouthful of chicken
when Pavlovian reflex gave
way to human awareness
and she realized
what was happening.
The Hooters World Wing Eating
Championship had begun.
Her destiny was at
the bottom of the pile
of poultry parts
in front of her.
She couldn't afford
to be reckless.
Every wing had to be
clean in order to count.
So she quickly rendered
each one to polished bone
before moving on to the next.
Behind her, a gorgeous
girl in emphatically tight
orange shorts held a
scorecard above her head.
The woman bounced and
smiled and cheered,
faking her enthusiasm
the way Charlie
imagined her mother
had taught her.
In part of her heart,
Charlie would always
bear a hateful jealousy
for women like this.
She begrudged them their
big, friendly breasts,
their happily bulging
hips, all the legible parts
of their bodies that spoke
'woman' in every language.
Charlie's inscrutable
frame would never
carry that confident
kind of currency
and she scored the pretty
girls for their oblivious luck.
When she was nine, she'd posted
a note on the fridge that said
'Charlie is a girl and she
needs new clothes.'" Oh, god,
now what's this doing?
Will you save me?
IMOGEN BINNIE: Oh,
yeah, that's weird.
Do y'all know anything
about technology?
RED DURKIN: Is this
is a tech-savvy crowd?
IMOGEN BINNIE: OK,
should be good.
RED DURKIN: OK, great.
Thank you.
IMOGEN BINNIE:
[INAUDIBLE] web thing.
RED DURKIN: So to
recover a little bit,
Charlie hates pretty girls.
"When she was nine,
she'd posted a note
on the fridge that
said 'Charlie is a girl
and she needs new clothes.
End of discussion.'
Some years earlier, to get
out of an intervention,
Charlie's father had
declared that the words 'end
of discussion' meant exactly
that in the Eaglehorne
household.
It was family law.
The phrase had been
employed when she was 12
and demanded to go on hormones
and most recently at 17
when she declared her
intention of becoming
a professional speed eater.
One minute down, one
bowl of wings eaten.
Charlie's heart
kicked like a mule.
Anxiety throbbed in her temple.
Her jaw stiffened too quickly.
She knew if she didn't calm
down and steady her pace,
she'd be lucky to
finish at all, but she
was operating on a level
baser than prudence.
It was the reptile
part of her brain
that was grabbing and
chewing and swallowing.
She couldn't hear
the sloppy roar
of the crowd or the grunting
gluttony of the competition.
Like the few other
women onstage, she
was pelted with the
countless ugly words
for 'girl' that fly so
easily from the mouths
of angry drunken men.
She blocked it out.
She'd had practice.
Tears and snot
gushed down her face.
She was soaked in a marinade
of sweat and Buffalo sauce.
Grab.
Chew.
Swallow.
Each spicy wing tasted
more like Styrofoam,
and her cheeks bulged
with unchewed meat.
Every bedraggled second
took a lifetime to pass.
It was beginning
to feel like home.
She'd been raised by a
pair of New England hippies
who'd moved to Alabama because
they liked the leaves in autumn
and equated dirt roads
with rustic honesty.
The Eaglehornes settled in
a truck-stop town outside
of Montgomery called
Hope Hull, which
was an appropriate name
for a place so utterly
gutted of anything worth
looking forward to."
Oh my god, it just did it again.
So I chose to read this story
because my other stories are
really gross and upsetting.
And now I'm like, ah, should've
just been gross and upsetting.
"The Eaglehornes settled in
a truck-stop town outside
of Montgomery called
Hope Hull, which
was an appropriate name
for a place so utterly
gutted of anything worth
looking forward to.
The 'Charlie is a
Girl' campaign had
been one of the most
successful political movements
in its entire history.
As a home-schooled
hippie whelp growing up
on the fringes of
an outskirt town,
she was practically
invisible to anyone
who didn't share
their meals with her.
Between her mother's
home-style lopsided haircuts
and her father's surprisingly
successful approach
to homeopathic endocrinology,
those lucky enough
to lay eyes on her
were neither certain of
nor curious about what
they were looking at.
Her parents claimed
her as their daughter
and, so long as you
didn't have the audacity
to dye your hair pink or the
nerve to be dark skinned,
Hope Hull's residents were
a proudly credulous bunch.
Charlie suddenly realized
she couldn't remember
last time she'd taken
oxygen into her lungs.
She wondered how long her
animal mind had been screaming.
All the pain and confusion
she'd foisted on it
were immediately hers
to deal with again.
Four more minutes had passed,
four and a half more bowls.
55 wings in all.
The top half of her body
was covered in gore.
Her jaw glowed
white-hot with pain,
her esophagus burning
with the sensation
of being strangled
from the inside out.
She tried to swallow, but
the blockage in her throat
only shuffled in place.
She snatched a cup of water from
the table and gulped it down.
The lump lurched mercifully.
As it finally moved to take its
rightful place in her stomach,
she gasped a great mouthful
of air and the agony
all over her body
began to register
on an all too conscious level.
Her fingers hurt.
She took another deep
breath and closed her eyes.
She forced herself
to master the pain.
She refused to go back to
hustling arrogant rednecks
at the off-ramp
burger joints that
composed Hope Hull's economy.
At one time, those
moments have been
proud and meaningful victories.
Now, they felt more
like the glory-day nails
in her inevitably
mediocre coffin.
She was willing to eat her way
out of that shit-splat town,
even if it killed her.
She picked up another
wing just in time
to catch a blur of green
glass in her periphery.
The bottle cracked her just
above the eye and everything
went white in an instant.
Charlie had been hit
before, of course.
By her mid-teens, she'd traded
her bean-pole adolescent
androgyny for a sexlessly
amorphous obesity.
To the idle and idiot
youth of Hope Hull,
Charlie was a chimera
of cardinal social sins.
She was fat, opinionated,
and ineffably weird looking.
She had the disturbing habit
of reading for pleasure
and her free-spirited
Yankee kin might as well
have been Martians.
The girls spit in her hair
and laughed at her back.
The boys called her a faggot
because she confused them.
They punched her,
she punched back,
and, slowly, they all learned
how to fight together.
Her sole companion
was a pig-nosed girl
named Lulu, who brazenly
forced the friendship
to garner disapproval
from her pig-faced family.
In fluttering flashes,
the world began to focus.
She'd staggered
back from the table
but was still in
the competition.
Precious seconds had been
lost to semi-consciousness,
and she warded off wary medics
to keep from losing more.
The red in her eye might
well have been Buffalo sauce.
Her throbbing head
reminded her of home.
She wanted to sleep.
She needed to eat.
She split the difference
and looked around.
Four more minutes
to go and only eight
of the original 20 competitors
still stood on the line.
For the first time she could see
that, just past the grits eater
and a bloated man wearing
novelty sunglasses,
stood Sonya Thomas,
The Black Widow.
She was a svelte
Korean-born woman
who had managed a Burger
King before becoming
the second highest ranked
gurgitator on Earth.
She held a dozen world
records and, according
to the scoreboard,
a chicken wing
that would put her 26
points out of reach.
Charlie's stomach suddenly
felt like a much smaller place.
Somewhere outside
of her body, she
could see herself chewing again.
She had never planned
on beating Sonya Thomas,
she had only prayed
she wouldn't show up.
Some people want to
kill their idols,
but Charlie didn't want a fight.
She just wanted to
get out of Alabama.
A mechanical waltz
settled over her body.
Grab.
Chew.
Swallow.
She struggled to distract
herself from the replete pain
and doubt welling
up in her guts.
She thought back to home and
the perpetual motion of her life
as a Podunk pariah.
In the dregs of
her diffidence, she
knew that she'd
fed the beast, had
let the hurt go deeper
than skin and had grown
fatter, weirder, even
meaner as a result.
She'd craved the hard touch of a
town that would never claim her
as their own, never love
her, never brag about her.
Her hope had been shining
through an ever-clenching
pinhole, but in
that lens she'd seen
The Widow competing
on television.
Charlie recognized her kindred
in strife, another misfit
among rubes.
She saw in Sonya Thomas a
whisper of freedom, a liberty
to dance on the edge of
womanhood and thrive.
Charlie's training had started
the spring she turned 17.
Her parents met her intentions
of becoming a major league
eater with a skepticism
bordering hostility.
17 years of
semi-responsible parenting
had severely moderated
the Eaglehorne idea
of acceptable life-goals.
Really, they worried that
their chronically unpopular
daughter's plan to etch a living
shoving food down her throat
was a proposition in suicide.
She'd had to declare
the discussion ended
more than once.
In fact, she'd never
been further from death.
Her regimen was
modeled on what she
could glean from her
idol's sporadic television
appearances and the internet.
It was surprisingly in step
with the recommendations
of modern medicine.
Eight hours of sleep at night,
daily jogs, and a strict 1700
calorie diet filled with
fruits and vegetables.
Of course, eating all that food
at once isn't in many fitness
manuals, to say nothing of
her biweekly all-you-can-eat
'workouts,' but the overall
improvement in Charlie's health
was undeniable.
By the fall, she'd
lost 78 pounds
and gained the
beauty and confidence
of a girl who truly believes
she has control over food.
Her public enthusiasm
of eating competitions
did her few favors
with her peers,
but her reclaimed
featherweight kilter
and the off-brand
hormones her father
bought online had given her
a peculiar prettiness that
at least kept boys from
throwing rocks at her.
Her friendship remained
a social pitfall
Lulu alone was willing to risk.
With 30 seconds
left, something was
very wrong and getting worse.
The 83 wings she'd
somehow swallowed
were now in open revolt.
Terror tied a knot in her
stomach, making her nausea
feel all the more urgent.
She'd eaten beyond her means.
Charlie was going to throw up.
Her breath came
in shallow gulps.
She wobbled drunkenly as
her strength began to break
and she closed her eyes.
Clammy certainty enveloped her.
Vomiting was intractable
and inevitable,
but desperately
needed to be stalled.
If a drop of her sick
touched the table
before the clock ran out,
she'd be disqualified.
A great wave of
adrenaline washed up
the last bit of resolve
she'd so jealously buried.
It was immediately followed
by the half-digested ambitions
at the back of her throat.
Charlie's hands
shot to her mouth.
A gleeful explosion
of pleasure roared out
of the voyeuristic crowd.
Her shoulders heaved
as though she'd
been shoved by an invisible
hand and she teetered slightly
forward.
The drool in her mouth
tasted like batteries.
The mess in her guts came
flooding out over her lips
and into her waiting palms.
She shuddered violently as
she buckled and began to fall.
The final buzzer screamed
out over the chaos.
The Championship was over.
Charlie's world
strobed into blackness
and she collapsed
unconscious into a pile
of puke and victory.
In her hallucinations, Charlie
watched the Big Bang spew forth
and begin to eat itself.
She perceived a cycle of
consumption, the tidal glut
of energy that crushes stars
and digests the cosmos.
At the center of each galaxy
sat an endlessly hungry mouth,
a black hole that bolted
down creation and waited
for the final
buzzer of doomsday.
Serenely, she
recognized creation
as an elaborate eating contest.
The thought made her happy.
She woke up to the bright white
glow of tarp in the sunshine.
Her head lay on a
starched, sterile pillow,
and a clear tube
of saline dripped
into a vein in the
crook of her elbow.
The ebullient bustle of
post-competition commotion
outside told her that she'd
been unconscious for only
a few minutes, though she felt
like she'd witnessed eternity.
Sitting up drew the
relieved attention
of a kind-faced young medic
on the other side of the tent.
Her heart fluttered,
her head throbbed,
and he urged her
to lie back down.
She'd almost died.
It was time to rest.
In a photo finish, Charlie's
vomit had stayed in her hands
and off the table
until after the buzzer.
The rules were clear--
she'd officially
finished successfully.
Charlie was awarded third
place, just five wings shy
of the grits guy.
On the plastic stool
next to her cot,
paper-clipped to a $500 check
and a handful of Hooters
coupons, was a business
card with the International
Federation of Competitive
Eaters logo on it.
She grinned deliriously,
belched, and fell asleep."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
IMOGEN BINNIE: It's always
awesome to watch the people who
kind of lose their
shit during that story.
I've seen Red read
that a lot of times.
It's nice.
My name is Imogen Binnie.
This is a novel
called "Nevada" that I
wrote that just lost at
the Lambda Literary Awards.
It's a story--
it's in two parts.
The first is about a trans woman
living in New York City who
is a mess, who loses her
girlfriend and her job.
In the second part, she sort
of half-borrows, half-steals
her now-ex-girlfriend's
car and points it west,
where she winds up at a Wal-Mart
in a small town in Nevada,
where she sees a kid--
she's in her late 20s.
She sees this kid, and
she's like, ah, you're 19,
and I know you.
You are trans and you
don't know it yet.
I'm going to fix that for you.
And he's like, I
don't know about that.
It's a story of
non-consensual mentorship.
And so what I'm
going to read-- I'm
going to read a part
from the first half of it
and then a part from the second
half of it when they meet.
Or am I?
I am.
So the first part I'm
going to read-- she
has broken up with
her girlfriend.
Her girlfriend broke up
with her a little bit ago.
And she just was
fired for her job
because she works at The Strand.
Do you know The Strand
in New York City?
She works at a bookstore.
She tends to kind of just
leave, walk around lower
Manhattan on the clock.
So she's just been
fired for that.
And that's that.
"You could be melodramatic
and say, just like that,
Maria Griffiths is homeless and
unemployed in New York City.
The reality, though, is that
she has a bunch of places
to crash, so it would be
appropriative to call herself
homeless.
OK, she says, great,
I'm just going
to grab my stuff from the back.
And then I'll be on my way."
She is in the process
of being fired.
"OK, she says,
great, I'm just going
to grab my stuff from the back.
And I'll be on my
way, all cheerful.
Someone will bring you
your things, McNealy says."
McNealy is an angry,
obviously, supervisor
who is in the process
of firing her.
"McNealy says.
You're really not
going to let me go back
to the closet to get my bag?
You don't work here anymore, he
says, looking off to one side,
already bored with
this conversation.
Some new kid brings her bag up.
They must have watched her
leave and prepared for this.
Awkward, but whatever.
Once again, her
response surprises her.
She's kind of excited.
She laughs in the old
fucker's face, takes her bag,
and walks back into the rain.
She practically knocks
over the terrifying owner
of the store, who has just
arrived in a cab or a car
service or whatever,
right on time for work."
I'm not going to read
this section for YouTube.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, wow, that's
a lot of stuff I
don't want to read on YouTube.
"Maria starts
immediately to regret
that she didn't get a
jab in, but whatever.
She's outside in the rain, and
she's got the whole afternoon
to herself-- the
whole week, actually.
It hits her again that
she's pretty excited
not to have a job anymore,
even though that means no more
money until she can find
another one and no more health
insurance.
Who cares?
She never has to
go back to that job
she was so indifferent about for
so long because she absolutely,
completely hates her
life in New York.
Whoa.
Sometimes, your internal
monologue surprises you.
She thinks about going back to
the apartment she is probably
still sharing with Steph,
but seeing all Steph's things
would probably be kind
of rough right now.
Then she thinks about going
to hang out with Piranha--"
her best friend
is named Piranha.
"She thinks about going
to hang out with Piranha,
but she is probably going
to be asking Piranha
if she can crash at her house
a lot pretty soon, so she had
better not just start taking
up space there immediately.
She could go see a movie,
but suddenly being broke
is a lot more real than
it was a couple hours ago,
and $10 for a
two-hour distraction
seems irresponsible,
like bad irresponsible.
She decides to go to Alt.Coffee.
It is this biggish coffee
shop on Avenue A where
they have computers and
stuff but also couches
and expensive coffee
and atmosphere.
It's cooler than the coffee
shop by the bookstore,
like in a gentrification sense.
As a last act of epic,
brutal, punk-rock defiance,
she steps two feet back into
the door of the bookstore
and grabs an umbrella out
of the umbrella basket.
Hah.
She leaves her bike chained
up outside the bookstore,
under the awning
where it'll stay dry,
and walks the six long blocks
to Avenue A. It's so gray out.
It rules.
This has been her
favorite kind of weather
since she was a little kid.
She loves going inside after
being in the rain when you're
kind of wet and cold, but you
immediately start warming up.
And you finally start
to feel just how wet you
are as soon as you
start to dry out.
And then you can look
outside and see the rain,
watch it run down the windows.
And nobody can realistically
ask you to go outside and play.
New Yorkers walk
by and ignore her.
Cabs splash puddle
water everywhere.
Nobody waits for
the Don't Walk sign
to turn to Walk before
they cross the street.
Rain looks like it's freezing to
the frail branches of the city
trees.
Maybe the rain will start to
freeze, turn the sidewalks icy.
It's fall, so it might happen.
But it's very early
fall, so it might not.
This umbrella is enormous, and
it's got a Nike logo on it.
Punk rock indeed, Batman."
She's been calling
herself Batman
in her internal monologue.
It's pretty wise.
"Punk rock indeed, Batman,
she says to herself
as she retracts the umbrella and
goes into the hip coffee shop.
They have an umbrella
bucket, and she
worries for a second about
whether someone will steal
her umbrella, then
laughs at herself.
Who cares?
It'd probably do her
some good for somebody
to steal her stolen
umbrella so she
would have to walk back
to her bike in the rain.
She thinks about how
good a hot shower feels
when you're soaked
in cold rain."
So here's the thing.
She's been thinking a lot
about knuckle tattoos,
and how if you
have eight letters,
you can make a knuckle tattoo.
The next line is
"Umbrella, she thinks,"
but it is spelled out in
blocks of four letters
so as to appear in the
shape of knuckle tattoos.
She's thinking about having
the word umbrella tattooed
on her knuckles.
"She didn't bring a book.
And she doesn't
really know what she's
going to do at the coffee shop--
spend money on internet access
to look at help wanted
ads on Craigslist?
Her resume from years
ago is probably somewhere
in her email.
She could update it to
include this most recent job,
act like she left
without being fired,
lie and say a friend
is a manager who
thinks she was a great employee.
She can use her real
name, not her legal one,
and just not freak out
about it if anybody asks,
just tell them she's
trans at the interview.
If she gets an
interview-- that way,
it'll be out in
the open, at least
with the management
at her new job, which
will be as somebody's
assistant at a publishing
company or something.
She gets a $3 drip coffee and
gives the barista her license.
She doesn't look at it,
but she's got dyke hair,
so she probably
wouldn't care if she
saw the M. Maria is
assigned computer number 23,
but after 15 minutes of
looking at Craigslist, her eyes
glaze over, and she is
falling asleep sitting up.
She doesn't have the
energy to email that girl.
She does not feel
like job searching.
She's like, do I even
want to stay in New York?
She doesn't actually have to.
She goes back up to the
counter, tells the girl
that she is done
on the computer,
and gets her license
back. $5 for 15 minutes.
She takes her coffee
over to a couch,
sits down, and takes
out her notebook.
October 15, part three.
I hate New York, but I love
the New York rain in autumn,
like the November rain.
But it is October,
and I just got
fired from the stupid bookstore.
I didn't even cuss out anybody.
Now I have to figure out what
the fuck to do with myself.
Do I get a new job in
Brooklyn near my apartment?
Except I'm going to have to
find another apartment, too.
I am exhausted from thinking
about being trans all the time,
and I wish I could stop.
If you work for the city of
San Francisco, dear diary,
did you know that they will
pay for bottom surgery for you?
It might be an urban legend.
Maybe I will look into it.
It didn't even occur to
me to go out and get drunk
after I got fired,
which is interesting.
It's almost like I
got drunk all the time
when I was dating Steph and
working a shitty job, not
because I am a total
addict, but because it
was a coping mechanism to
deal with being unhappy.
Her hand hurts already.
It sucks that being from the
computer generation means she
cannot write longhand,
like, at all.
She texts Piranha.
Can I stay with
you again tonight?
Got fired a little.
She puts the phone
back in her pocket,
but it rings immediately.
It's Piranha.
She stands up and goes
outside, because who
cares what everybody
else does, who
cares that there are only three
other people in the coffee
shop at 2:00 PM on a Wednesday.
It is rude to talk
on your phone when
other people are
trying to concentrate.
Dude, Piranha says.
Hi, Maria says, maybe more
cheerful than she actually is.
I'm working tonight,
but you can come
get the key from me at work and
stay at my house while I'm out
and, like, take a
shower or whatever.
Thanks, Maria says.
But listen, you can't just
stay at my house all the time,
you know?
Yeah, I was--
Piranha cuts her off.
I know you know,
but it's like, dude,
Maria, besides the
occasional text,
I hear from you once every two
or three months because you're
so occupied with your
girlfriend all the time.
And now suddenly, you want
to hang out all day every day
because you don't have to
worry about her anymore?
It feels kind of fucked to me.
Shit.
Yeah.
I--
No, listen, Piranha says.
I'm not going to put
you out on the street,
especially if you just
got fired from work.
And I want you to tell
me all about that.
I'm not super pissed
at you or anything.
I just need you to
understand that I
feel kind of resentful
about the fact
that you've ignored me
pretty bad for so long.
And now that you've got a
reason besides that you're
excited to hang out
with me, suddenly we
are besties or whatever.
OK, Maria says, probably
hurt the most deeply
that she's been in
these last couple days.
I miss you, Piranha says, and
I'm excited to see you again.
But I needed to
put that out there.
I've got to go to work at 9:00.
Come see me then, OK?
Yeah, Maria says.
OK.
They hang up.
Now her mood has come back to
earth, and she feels like shit.
Maybe she should get a beer.
Turns out they have two-for-one
beers after 4:00 at HiFi
half a block away, but Maria
doesn't wait until 4:00.
Then, when 4 o'clock hits, she
has her third and fourth beers
and falls asleep on the
bar for a couple hours.
Who knows why the skinny,
pretty bartender lets her sleep.
That's kind of off
limits at most bars.
Maybe having a transsexual pass
out at your bar for a couple
hours is the kind of
gritty authenticity
that a bar on the
Lower East Side
needs now that everybody
has moved to Brooklyn."
That's the first part
I'm going to read.
This next section is from
the perspective of James,
who is 19.
He's smoking a lot
of weed so he doesn't
have to think about gender or
have any feelings about gender.
"He smokes out before
he gets to work,
but by hour four of so
of a nine-hour shift,
he is not really
feeling stoned anymore.
Every day by this point,
he mostly feels tired
and pissed off.
He's always wished he could
be the kind of cool badass
who smokes out at
work, but there
is no way you could do
without somebody finding out.
Plus, his mom rides
in his car sometimes,
so you can't even
hotbox it ever.
It's actually very
possible that this
is why he hates his job so much.
He's like, I should
think about that.
Every single day, I go through
an unstonedening and fucking
hate my life and my job and
my house and my girlfriend
and everyone and
everything that I can see.
It seems like that probably
affects my job satisfaction.
I end each shift
with a headache.
I need a fix because
I am addicted
to the she-demon marijuana.
It is getting toward
the end of his shift,
and James isn't stoned
anymore, and it sucks.
This old guy who comes
in once or twice a week
was looking for some
stupid old movies
that he couldn't find
because Wal-Mart does not
carry stupid old movies.
But this guy doesn't
listen to James at all,
so they always wind up
spending half an hour
pretending to look for these
DVDs that are not there.
That's probably a metaphor for
life in Star City, actually.
Whatever.
Once or twice a week,
James thinks very seriously
about writing out a note to
have waiting for this guy
the next time he comes in that
explains that these are very,
very old and hokey
movie starring actors
that nobody cares about anymore,
and that he would be better off
going to the Family Dollar over
in [? Imlay ?] where they sell
those mass-produced DVDs of
public domain stuff that feel
all light in your hands
like there's no DVD in them.
Wal-Mart can't even order them.
Those DVD companies have
their own distributors
that Wal-Mart doesn't
use, which is weird,
since it seems like
the distributors that
make those wholesome
DVDs would be Christian.
And Wal-Mart doesn't shy
away from Christian anything.
But whatever.
Who cares?
James has a headache.
He needs to smoke out
again, and this old guy
is starting to seem done with
playing out this scenario yet
again, when Maria Griffiths
comes strutting up
the aisle of the Wal-Mart
looking out of place as hell,
like she is made out of long
red hair and layers of clothing.
James does anybody
would do when they
see somebody they
would like to know.
He ignores the shit out of her.
Probably, he freaks
out a little.
But she came right to
the Music and Movies
section, so what
else could he do?
He says hi to her when she first
comes in because he can get
in trouble if he doesn't.
According to Wal-Mart
corporate policy,
greetings turn
thieves into friends.
But then he just
ignores her as hell.
Maybe on some level,
he notices that she
might have looked at him
for a second longer than was
appropriate.
But if he half thinks anything,
it's like, suck it up, dude.
That girl is definitely
not checking you out.
She's wearing more
clothes than he has ever
seen anyone wear at once-- huge
black boots, a long black skirt
or maybe a dress, what
looks like a shorter
dark orange skirt on top
of it, a long maroonish
sweater under a ratty denim
jacket with a bunch of patches
and buttons on
it, a black scarf,
and wavy dried-out-looking
hair just past her shoulders.
Her hair is almost exactly
the same color as her sweater,
but a little bit darker.
They probably clash or whatever.
Her clothes look like
she slept in them.
There are
permanent-looking crinkles
in the elbows of her
jacket, and her hair
looks like it would
leave a mark if she
leaned her head against a wall.
She looks like she is probably
a rock star or a murderer.
One time, the band Creed
came to his Wal-Mart
on tour to buy
batteries or something.
And everybody flipped out, even
though Creed is a stupid band.
But James saw one of
the guys from the band,
and he walked with this
magnetism or swagger
or something, like he
knew he was a big deal.
And Maria carries herself
kind of the same way.
She walks over to the
Pop/Rock CD display.
And James thinks clearly,
who the fuck wears a scarf
in the daytime in Star City,
especially during a heat wave?
While he is ignoring her,
he stares at her back."
This is good.
I bet Google people
will get this, ready?
"Who the fuck wears a scarf
in the daytime in Star City,
especially during a heat wave?
While he is ignoring her,
he stares at her back.
Steven Tyler?
The Fourth Doctor?"
Yeah, great.
There's always one or
two people who are like,
you didn't just-- cool.
It's a "Doctor Who" allusion.
James watches a lot of TV.
"He is seriously
just being a creep
and staring at
her because people
who look like that
do not live here.
They don't stop here while
they're driving through,
either.
There are other Wal-Marts
closer to the highway,
like three exits away
in either direction.
It was fucking dumb for
Wal-Mart to put a Wal-Mart here.
Well, nobody comes
here except for Creed.
Once.
She flips through the
Pop/Rock CDs for a second.
And James manages to
look away from the Poison
patch safety-pinned across her
back and the messy, wavy hair
sprawling its way down it.
Like, Poison?
The glam rock band with the
singer who does reality TV
shows now?
His headache fades, or else
James just forgets about it.
Because when she turns
around, he's very intently
alphabetizing CDs that have just
come in and need to be shelved.
Hey, she says, looking
him up and down again.
James is like, Hi.
Do you have the
Miranda Lambert album?
Um, he says, probably,
but it's probably
in the country section.
She's like, Oh, there's
a country section?
And he's like, Well, yeah.
Then, because he is
feeling totally weird,
James doesn't even stop himself.
He just blurts
out, You don't look
like the folks who usually
shop there, though.
Because if he is being
totally honest with himself
on some level, James
has already figured out
that this girl is trans.
And while he hasn't processed
what that means yet,
he is having this desperate,
magnetic attraction to her,
like not even
sexual, just like, I
want to be your Facebook friend.
I need to grab you, to have
you in my life, whatever.
You don't look like the
folks who usually shop here--
that is a pretty dumb thing to
say, but she doesn't disagree.
She looks at his name
tag, smirks, and says,
That's probably true, James
H., but check this out.
I left New York City
about a week ago.
And my dog, my cat, and I
have been living out of my car
since then, driving
out to the West Coast
solely because we
have never seen it.
In New York City, there
are Spanish music stations,
rap stations, dumb
rock stations,
and little stations run by
painfully self-aware college
students with no idea what to
do with all their privilege
besides collect records in
gentrified neighborhoods that
have been fine for generations.
But I don't think there's a
country station in New York.
I guess there are a lot of
reggaeton stations, which
in a lot of ways,
people tend to not even
notice has a lot of
similarities to country music."
By the way, people
have asked me,
oh, yeah, how is reggaeton
similar to country?
It's not.
This is Maria being an idiot.
Anyway, "It turns out,
though, that once you
leave New York-- which
nobody should ever do, ha ha.
JK, the only things
you can consistently
get on a 12-year-old car stereo
are NPR and country stations.
And have you ever
listened to NPR?
It's soothing, for a while.
But eventually, it makes
you want to call in
and cuss somebody
out until you cry.
It wouldn't get onto
the radio because I
guess they have enough lag time
to dump out angry people who
call up and lose their shit.
But it turned me
off NPR for a while,
which means country
station after country
station for the last four days.
And look, I am not
some New York jerk
who thinks country music
is for yokels or something.
I'm into it.
I get it.
I even think it's kind of
nice that country singers are
so fucking convinced of
their own sincerity that they
don't do any of the
tortured artist,
'I don't care if you
like me, it's art,
man,' posturing that all
the indie rock kids do.
And they don't spend
all day telling me
about how tough and rich
they are, like the rappers
on the radio do,
except, James H.,
there is also a lot of
dumb shit on country radio.
'I'm So Much Cooler Online'?
'She Thinks My Tractor's Sexy'?
I guess it's funny the
first time, but, but--
Maria has followed James over
to the country music section
and is jabbing her pointer
finger toward his chest.
I guess, she says,
Miranda Lambert
isn't the biggest star
in the country sky
because I have only heard the
radio play her a couple times.
But I think all her
songs are about,
like, burning down cheating
ex-boyfriend's houses
and, like, shooting your
abusive ex in the face.
The first time I heard
that song, I was like,
finally, someone is just
coming out and threatening
to kill her asshole boyfriend
right there on the radio.
Not that I think anybody should
kill anybody else or anything,
but after five days of country
radio, consider me brainwashed.
Miranda Lambert, James H., is
the punkest shit on the radio,
and I am going to drive
my car off a cliff
if I hear the song about how
the guy hopes he gets a chance
to live like he was
dying ever again.
Not because I don't
like it, because it
is so sad and true
that it makes me
want to live like I
was dying and then die.
So James H., Miranda Lambert
is a contingency plan
to save my life.
She actually said the
internet abbreviation
for just kidding out loud.
There's a pause,
and then she smirks.
And she's like, Sorry,
I haven't really
talked to anybody in a while.
James is like, It's cool.
He picks up Miranda
Lambert's second album
and hands it to her.
This is the CD with that
song about the gunpowder
and lead on it, he says.
Thank you, James H., she says.
You've been very helpful.
Then she starts to leave the
Movies and CDs department.
Wait, James says.
You've got to buy it here, or
else security will kick my ass.
This is kind of true.
Mostly true-- you're supposed
to get people to buy their music
and DVDs in the Music
and DVDs section.
Even though there isn't
like a rule about it,
it's a firm suggestion in the
interest of loss prevention.
But it is a stupid thing
to emphasize just then.
It's not like he's
going to slip her
his phone number on the receipt.
Well, the receipt does
have the phone number
for Wal-Mart number 8304 on
it, if she wants to call him.
I don't think they could
take you, she says.
You look like a total bruiser.
Yeah, he says, totally.
I'm a regular old Brad Paisley."
We were just talking about
Brad Paisley in the car before.
Brad Paisley is great.
"I'm a regular old Brad Paisley.
Which one is Brad Paisley?
You know, he says.
I don't highlight my hair
and I've still got a pair.
Maria's eyes light up, and she
quotes from this dumb country
song.
My eyebrows ain't plucked,
and there's a gun in my truck.
That's me, he says.
Honey, I'm still a guy.
It's $10.90.
The weirdness of that exchange
is not lost on either of them.
Maria pays with a debit card.
James notices that
her PIN is 6664.
Then she leaves, and
he thinks, well, fuck.
Then his headache is back,
and he gets pretty bummed.
So he starts thinking
about how, like, soon he's
going to go home and
get high as fuck.
Smoking weed rules, and the fact
that this girl just showed up
in his life and now she is
gone forever totally sucks.
He's thinking about this
weird girl who was just here,
whose name he doesn't
even know because she
paid with a PIN
instead of credit.
And then his thoughts naturally
and optimistically turn
to his go-to non-sexual
fantasy, weed.
He is envisioning,
like, laying down
in the sprawling
fields of the marijuana
farms of northern California,
but she keeps stomping in.
Even though it is
his go-to fantasy,
James is aware that
it is pretty boring.
More interesting
things tend to intrude,
like fantasizing about laying
down in a field of weed crops.
It's like licking the centerfold
of an issue of 'High Times.' He
just keep thinking,
like, New York City.
Her and a dog and a cat
in a car for a week--
what the fuck is reggaeton?
Trans.
It's weird that he could
tell that she was trans.
You could tell, but not
in like an obvious way,
like if a drag queen came
parading up the aisle.
You couldn't really tell
from the way she looked
or the way she
talked or anything.
Probably.
But then you have to ask
yourself, like, well,
how could I tell?
It was probably some
combination of things,
but could other people tell?
Was he going to have to
have stupid conversations
for the next three
months with idiot
co-workers about
the freaky queer
that was in the
store that one time?
Gross.
Weird."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CASEY PLETT: Hi, everyone.
I'm Casey Plett.
I'm the last one.
I'm going to read a
story out of this book
that I just wrote, called
"A Safe Girl to Love,"
which is a collection
of short stories.
They're all about
young trans women.
I'm going to read part of
a story-- couple excerpts--
that I haven't read yet, which
is a story called "Winning."
And it is set in Eugene,
Oregon, out in the northwest.
And it is about a
girl and her mom.
I'm just going to start
at the beginning, so.
"He's shivering, Zoe thought,
as she came in Robin's bedroom
and saw his tall,
muscle-and-pudge body vibrating
on the bed, blanket
on the floor.
She made to tuck
the blanket back
over him when she saw
his face was contorted
and his lips were
moving like waves.
She said, 'Hey,' and
softly rocked his shoulder.
Robin gasped.
Then his face turned
instantly blithe.
'Hey, I'm sorry to wake you.'
'It's OK,' he said.
He stretched, and his
boxers made a ruffling noise
in the sheets. 'You're
leaving?' he said.
'Yeah,' she said. 'Thanks
for letting me crash.'
'Definitely.
Boy,' he yawned.
'I feel fucked up.'
Robin finished most of
a magnum last night.
Zoe'd had two glasses
and switched to milk.
She loved milk.
She giggled and said, 'Aw,'
and mussed his wavy brown hair.
It was silly, she realized,
walking outside and zipping
her hoodie up over
her dress, but she
had forgotten that boys
even had nightmares at all.
It was mid November, when
in the Pacific Northwest,
the panorama of clouds
stopped flirting with the sky
and moved in and set their
parking brakes until May.
A soft mist patter of
rain was coming down
as Zoe walked down the
motel-like stairs of Robin's
complex, then over
to Eugene Station
to take the 66 bus north.
She got on and texted her best
friend Julia back in New York.
Hi, she said.
You're beautiful, and I
miss you to fucking pieces.
When she got off the bus
and walked up to Ayres Road,
the rain had
stopped, but the sky
was still an ocean
of pearl gray.
Zoe hated this.
Humans aren't
supposed to go months
with all their sunlight
broken, she thought.
She had actually loved
the winters in New York.
Everyone there
complained about gray,
but to Zoe, New York had
been sunny and bright.
Back at her mom's, the boxes
in the kitchen hadn't moved.
There was a note on
the counter which said,
I've gone to the farmers
market one last time.
I need everything out
of your room tonight.
Well, that was a new request.
She still had a week to
stay here, but whatever.
She went into her room and
resumed clearing out her shit.
You can build up
so much stuff when
you have a room in a house
you don't actually live in,
she thought.
And Zoe'd always been a pack
rat, even as a teenager.
She would save a
lot of the things
that she thought regular
families saved with their kids.
But she'd done most of
that stuff now, though.
And there were only a few
boxes left-- orderly seas
of social studies papers, choir
programs, stuff like that.
Sandy came home
as Zoe was mashing
a basketball-sized paper
wad into the recycling.
'I bought some food for
you,' her mother said.
'I'm not hungry,' said Zoe.
'Don't give me that.
Have you eaten?'
'I don't want any food, thanks.'
Sandy washed a bag
of Bartlett pears
and plunked it,
dripping, on the counter.
She put her elbows beside the
bag and massaged her eyes.
'Better to tell me the
truth, don't you think?'
Ever since Zoe transitioned,
Sandy had become convinced that
her daughter would develop
an eating disorder,
though Zoe was eating as
little as ever. 'No, thanks,
Mom,' Zoe said.
'I'm not hungry.'
'Zoe,' Sandy said, 'the last
thing I want to do is have
to make you eat.
It's not like I like having this
conversation.' Sandy was trans,
too.
Zoe had come out to her
exactly 18 months ago,
on the phone from her
Brooklyn apartment
after she'd already been
on hormones for a while.
She'd meticulously taken
steps to avoid telling her.
And when she had, her mother
had cried and cried and cried.
Her phone pulsed, and Zoe
saw another text from Julia.
You're beautiful.
I miss you.
And Zoe picked up
the biggest pear
and took a gargantuan bite.
'What do you need help
with next?' she asked.
Sandy had done a lot to
have Zoe with Sandy's wife
at the time, [? Tea ?].
This was back in the mid '80s.
Sandy had sent the
forged death certificate
to the clinic where she'd
banked her sperm, who then sent
the samples to a friend
of Tea's, a nurse
practitioner, who then
helped with inseminating.
This was on the plains, where
Sandy and Tea had grown up.
They'd moved to
Oregon to have Zoe,
who was born downtown in an
apartment off Eighth Avenue.
Zoe loved this
story, and she never
got tired of telling
her friends back east.
She liked to say that
she had been born loved.
Though Tea left both of
them when Zoe was eight,
and Sandy had not always been
the most stable of mothers,
Zoe had always
felt acres of love.
'Can you go through the closet
in the spare room?' Sandy said.
'No problem,' said Zoe.
'Hey, have another
pear if you want it.
They're completely yours,'
Sandy called after her.
Zoe didn't respond, so she
got out pita bread and hummus
and went to her desk in the
living room to do paperwork.
She passed well, her mother did.
Zoe had always
admired her for that.
And now that she herself
had transitioned,
she especially admired it now.
In the old days, no one
had known about Sandy.
And with her being 6' 1" and
broad-shouldered and poor,
Zoe thought it really
couldn't have been easy.
'I always wore jeans,' Sandy
told Zoe once when Zoe was 17.
It had been the
fifth anniversary
of Sandy's bottom surgery, and
she'd been unusually talkative
about the subject.
'I always wore jeans,' she
said, 'almost never skirts
or dresses.
Because just in people's
heads, subconsciously,
the idea of trannies wearing
jeans doesn't mesh.' Zoe had
listened to this raptly.
'They said I looked
mannish,' Sandy giggled,
'but they never
thought I was a man.
I tricked them.' And she
sounded like she was gloating.
She said, 'You know,
they just passed me off
as some big, earthy dyke.
Well, you know, that's OK.'
From very early
in her childhood,
Zoe knew that Sandy had
once lived as a man.
Neither of her mothers
had hidden it from her,
but it was also understood to
be a buried subject, something
gravely serious Zoe was never
supposed to talk or ask about.
'I did have some really pretty
dresses,' Sandy had said
in that conversation, 'but I
had to be very careful about
wearing them.
I just had to be careful.'
They moved out of the
apartment off Eighth
when Zoe was in third grade.
It had been right after
Tea left and right
when Sandy got her
job with the county.
That's when they got one
of the few bungalows left
along [? Ayres ?], on
the north edge of town
just shy of the city line.
Sandy was from the country, and
she missed the stars, she said.
She missed the stars
and the quiet."
Skipping to another
section, more middle way
through the story.
So now Zoe has just gotten a job
at a call center doing surveys.
And this is her
first day at work.
"On the third
call, she stuttered
a bit because the man on
the phone, a surly dairy
farmer outside Pacific
City, sounded exactly
like a man she'd known
back in New York,
a guy with layered blond hair
who ran a bar in Williamsburg
wallpapered with
covers of Gaddis books.
They had gone out for
dinner, then out dancing.
The man had been amazingly
charming, gentlemanly.
She accepted all the
drinks he bought her.
And back at his place, he
began squeezing her nipples
and slipping his hand south.
And her last memory was of
mushily shaking her head, wait,
hold on, I like you, I
want you, it's like-- wait.
And when she woke up,
she was on his bed alone.
And he was at his
desk on his computer,
and both sides of her bottom
had a dull, vomit-spurring ache.
'How many milk-giving cows
did you say?' said Zoe now.
'I'm sorry, including
heifers that are not yet--'
'52,' said the man. 'Now,
do you have it this time,
or do I need to repeat it again?
You tell me here.'
And Zoe said, 'Yes, of
course, of course, sir."
And by 9 o'clock, Zoe had
covered the scratch paper
on her office desk with black
and white penciled swirls
and shapes, crisscrossing
paisleys and hexagrams
and triple helixes and
the outlines of faces.
Some of the faces
resembled her mom.
Her mom-- Zoe had always seen
her mother as dimly gorgeous.
She had short, coiffed
ash-blonde hair
like Sharon Stone in
'Casino' without the rattail.
She wore blue or green
skinny jeans, tank
tops with shiny satin edges
that showed off lightly
muscled swimmer's arms
and long earrings that
skittered around her collarbone
wherever she moved her head.
In winter, she wore
cable-knit zippered hoodies.
Zoe, on the other hand,
kept her hair black,
liked dresses with stripes or
polka dots, see-through blouses
over camisoles, with patterned
sweater tights in winter.
She sped through tubes
of eyeliner and lipstick.
Sandy maybe used a little
mascara once in a while.
Even as Zoe took no
part of her own style
from her, if she
had to be honest,
she dressed a bit like
her other mother, Tea,
who now spoiled her
with clothes on visits.
Zoe did admire the
way Sandy looked.
She admired a lot about
her mother, really.
She admired the way she hadn't
hid from Zoe the pain of Tea
leaving her, but she
rarely badmouthed
or castigated Tea herself.
And given that Tea had departed
with a load of their money
and a note including the words
'like anyone else would have
loved you,' she would
have had plenty of reason.
She admired how Sandy
treated Zoe's boyfriends
in high school, the
ones she dragged up
from south or the U of O--
because no gay boys were out
at her own school-- and how
Sandy welcomed them and cooked
for them even when sometimes
they were snotty to her.
She admired the sex
talks Sandy had given her
when she was really
young, before puberty.
Sandy had told her,
'Now, this is a thing
that teenagers and adults like
to do, and they get to do.
Kids don't.
It's not a kid thing.
You won't even want to
do it, and you shouldn't.
But this is what'll
happen when you're older.
And it can be wonderful.
But it is important you're safe.
There's a safe way to
do it and an unsafe way.
And it's like driving
without a seat belt,
where if something bad
happens, you can die.
But if you're safe,
it gives you freedom.
You can't imagine the
happiness and the freedom.
When you're older, I will help
you, and we can talk about it.
This is something I
want you to do right,
and it's something I want
you to look forward to.
I want this to be a good and
healthy part of your life,' she
had said.
And Zoe really admired that,
especially when she found out
about all of Sandy's
friends who'd
died during what she had
only referred to as a plague.
Zoe had remembered a
few of them from when
she was a kid, but only
faintly, and only a few.
'Thanks for your time, sir,'
Zoe said to her last call.
'Yeah, yeah, good night,
ma'am,' the man grumbled.
Zoe folded the drawings she
made, thought of sticking them
in her bag, then dropped
them in the trash--
not the recycling, the trash.
'So New York, huh?' the
supervisor asked as they left
their building
together after work.
'Why'd you come here?'
Zoe was really tired of
answering that question.
And lately, she'd
just been snapping,
'I'm helping my
mom' in a tone that
made everyone think her
mom had a deadly illness
and needed Zoe to tend to
her last days or something.
It usually got people
to leave her alone.
But when she said that
now, her super--" whew.
Too much coffee.
"But when she said that now,
her supervisor just said, 'Huh.
But do you like it here, though?
Like, do you think you want
to stay here in Eugene?'
Zoe considered how to
answer that to a stranger.
'Well, I grew up
here,' she said softly.
Walking down dark and slick
Willamet Street with her hoodie
up in the sprinkle-mist
rain, it occurred to her
that she'd walked these streets
late often since coming back,
but hadn't been propositioned
or harassed once in Eugene,
or made to feel unsafe
in any way, really.
When Zoe was a kid, she thought
she lived in a great town.
She thought no place was
better than this little city,
a term Tea had liked to
use-- 'Oh, this little city.'
Zoe didn't like the
neighborhood they'd ended up in,
a weird little bumpkin and
religious yuppie enclave,
but she loved downtown
and she love the U of O.
And she even loved the
dumb political battles
that played out in
the city-- bike paths
through the Catholic school,
the cross in Skinner's Butte,
where to build the new
hospital, all the little clashes
between right and left,
hippies and Mormons, developers
and enviros.
It had felt like
that stupid idea
of what America
was supposed to be.
And no one was from there.
It was a place you moved to.
Even from middle
school on, it seemed
like being born in town
put her in the minority.
And when she was a
teenager, leaving just
didn't occur to her.
Like, why would you do that
if you were lucky enough
to be from here?
She thought when she
left home that she'd just
get a room in a
house back downtown
by the [INAUDIBLE] Hall and
go be a stupid duck for four
years, then get a job and
a little house of her own.
And there she be.
There she be, as her mom
would say in one of her few
kept Midwesternism.
Zoe was rarely bitter
about being trans.
If you needed to believe in the
possibility of unbitter trans
women, Zoe would be your girl.
But she knew she
wouldn't have left
if it hadn't been for that.
She would have stayed.
She would have gone
to the country fair,
signed on with a coop,
checked in on her mom,
lived the beautiful
neoliberal American life.
It had been so close.
Hell, on the face of it,
the town in its current era
had been designed specifically
for someone like her.
Like, who else if not for
the fag kid of a woman
like Sandy, queer and
transplanted and a hippie
to boot?
Zoe had really always
thought it was a great town.
She'd never hated it growing
up-- ever, ever, ever.
But she knew that staying
meant a boy future,
a pretend-to-be-cis future.
She didn't have the
strength to figure out
the gender thing on
everyone she'd known.
And she'd known that
in part from her mom.
You couldn't transition
and keep everything else
in your life the same.
It couldn't happen.
She tested it that
one summer by telling
a few friends about Sandy,
the ones she thought
would react the best.
And the looks on their
faces-- especially her
boyfriend's-- a
revulsion, a horror,
the things they said
about her mother.
One just said simple dumb
stuff like, 'Oh, gross, she's
your dad.
That is fucked up.
That is fucked up.'
And another said,
'Huh, well, she
was too pretty to
actually be real, anyway.
Hey, maybe he'll be
a penguin next, huh?'
Though the worst was a
girl, a close friend, who
had looked ashen, then
said, 'You know, it sucks.
I knew she had
problems, but I still
looked up to her
as a strong woman.
I thought I had this
strong woman in my life.
I thought you had
this strong mother.'
Zoe clammed up about
telling anyone after that.
She didn't even mention
it to Frankie--"
an old best friend of hers.
"And so when fall came and
she applied for and squeaked
into a fancy school
on the east coast,
she saw for the first time in
her town a void, endless black.
She would be forever
grateful she grew up there.
But the future she saw was
for some willowy gay kid--
lovely, but not her.
I mean, everyone's
fucking attitudes
about trans stuff changed so
quickly after a few years.
Chaz, Thomas Beatie,
all those fucks--
had she been born
five years later,
she thought sometimes
she might have
felt like she could've stayed.
So.
Zoe was bitter about that.
She looked away
from her supervisor
and adjusted her bag.
'I don't mind it,'
she said quietly.
'There's a lot of
worse places to be.'
'Oh, gee,' said the supervisor.
'You have no idea.
I love it here.' And he started
talking about his hometown
in Arizona, and how there were
grocery stores and bars here
in Eugene he just loved.
And you'd never find
that where he was from,
and just even the people
were so nice, like they give
a shit about being
humans here, you know?
He had great eyes, and they
kind of sparked as he talked.
Zoe said, 'Uh-huh, totally,' and
decided to picture this guy Al
lubed and naked until they
got to the bus station,
where she returned some
texts and her supervisor got
on the 24 going somewhere south.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]